for more on the midterm results so far
in what they mean we're joined Now by
someone who knows a thing or two about
running for office senator Amy Klobuchar
of Minnesota joins us good to see you
Senator you know the Democrats did much
better than expected last night thank
you we're very glad you got up early
with us because I know I'll bet it was a
long night for you too but the Democrats
yeah I wanted to wear her sunglasses as
well
during her entire report but continue I
know Senator we can all relate to that
we really can but listen the Democrats
did much better than expected last night
what if anything surprised you about the
showing
well a number of things so many
Republicans and pundits were out there
predicting this red tide and let's just
say those predictions did not age well
uh first thing is we won a number of
Governors races as you have just noted
across the country including in States
like Minnesota and Michigan including a
red red State like Kansas where Governor
Kelly was reelected then you go to the
House of Representatives uh since 1974
the average loss of House Seats in a
midterm has been 20 23 and so we have
literally defied the tides of history no
matter what happens we know it's going
to be incredibly close in the house with
people like Abigail spanberger winning
our suit finally the Senate that was a
big one addicted this our incumbents
doing incredibly well and ahead and
fetterman winning in Pennsylvania but
privately many Democrats were worried
you weren't concerned last night going
into the races I know the Republicans
scale you were no okay
the money that had been spent against
our candidates uh the angry angry uh
types of ads that we saw on TV and what
I think is amazing about the voters
number one they showed up in big numbers
many of the election deniers lost the
voters have understood that democracy
has on the ballot number two I think we
were pushed at for pushing on the issue
of Reproductive Rights there are a lot
of criticisms but for a number of Voters
that mattered they showed up at the
polls because of the outrageous decision
by the Supreme Court third thing is
inflation costs our candidates have
pragmatic answers of bringing costs down
for families including taking on the
Pharma companies and I think the people
of this country understood more than the
pollsters of the pundits thought that
Democrats I've been doing a whole lot to
help and that in fact the Republicans
didn't really have a plan and they were
playing politics with it with a problem
that's a worldwide provide inflation
problem
yeah Senator you mentioned Those ads and
as you know messaging does matter exit
polls show voters trust Republicans more
than Democrats on issues like crime and
economy what can Democrats do to change
that moving forward
great question I think number one as a
house recently did putting forward plans
to go after crime and that includes
funding the police right before we broke
the Congress to come back home there was
a major vote in the house on funding the
police I lead the bill on funding
Community police officers with Lisa
murkowski of Alaska I think that's going
to be really important going forward
that we continue to make that clear and
that we actually helped to solve this
problem and there's many solutions
including mental health including
recruiting police officers that fentanyl
many things that we have to deal with
the second thing is of course on
inflation to me that means continuing
this work on Workforce training on the
supply chain disruptions I'm bringing
the shipping costs down on doing more
when it comes to pharmaceutical costs
and housing and child care instead of
focusing on enshrining tax cuts for the
the wealthy which was basically the
Republican plan as well so Senator
Social Security and Medicare go ahead so
Senator it's Vlad let me just ask you
about something that you were critical
of throughout this election cycle you
were critical of the party strategy of
spending millions of dollars supporting
election deniers in Republican primaries
because they thought it they would be
easier to win in general elections um it
seems to have worked but I don't know do
you think it's a good strategy going
forward
again that'll all be analyzed after
we're not after three hours sleep here
of what happened I think you see this
going on on both sides no I don't like
it
um I believe in our democracy but all of
this can continue and will continue to
happen on both sides unless we have some
kind of campaign Finance reform in place
and to me that means the freedom to vote
act it means a constitutional amendment
to overturn citizens united the angry
ugly ads coming from Untold sources of
money that no one can figure out Shadow
contributions that's got to end it's
really bad for our democracy yeah
Senator klobuchad just like many of us
here at CBS you make three hours of
sleep look good thank you for joining us
we appreciate you
you're welcome